this guy flying from Atlanta to Spain
transatlantic flight out of Atlanta in
like an hour into the flight
they have to turn around
because there's a passenger on the
flight with explosive diarrhea that has
basically created a biohazard on the
flight but you go to Spain oh yeah
that's what I'm saying like I was
immediately I didn't try to find coffee
down the [__] depositing diarrhea
around the plane became a biohazard they
had to turn around
so he was just [__] outside of the
bathroom but no one it's not exactly
confirmed but people are thinking that
he destroyed the bathroom [__] all over
the bathroom part of it leaking out the
bottom and then as he's going back and
forth to the seat he's eventually
dropping [__] throughout the plane in
certain spots is what people are
claiming through the New York Post
Office
[__] right it's like that's crazy yeah
that's legit crazy but also maybe he's
just his tummy hurts nah this crazy
[__] keeps it in the bathroom at
least yeah I can get the ball didn't
hurt that bad it hurt pretty bad
you never [__] on the ground though
because it hurt that bad I have shut the
ground that's my point so you've had
really really bad and you've had very
bad where your tummy hurts but you keep
well you don't need to show on the
ground if the toilet's right there yeah
yeah but what if it's a little far away
you got to get over people and you have
explosive diarrhea no you just go to the
toilet and you sit there that's my point
you've never had explosive diarrhea I
don't think this is real I do I don't
think that's real according to Pilot it
says there was feces all over the
aircraft not possible yeah this is a
crazy person he was going crazy yeah
this is well maybe it was a monkey
come on it's disgusting yeah that's
disgusting why Wow
chimpanzee it's really disgusting my bad
that was very insensitive to monkeys all
I have to say exposure diary is a real
thing I acknowledge that it's real
unlike you that's denying that I'm an
explosive thyroid denyer is that what
you're saying I've had explosive
diarrhea to where I couldn't wait I
couldn't hold it and it happened and it
got all over me where I had a soccer
game you were just nervous
have we heard this story before I never
heard this one you [__] yourself
in a game when I was a young boy
[Laughter]
a simply a boy how old were you is this
why you had to be homeschooled because
you couldn't miss cause again
yeah during a free kick and then my mom
told the school that I died
but didn't your mom actually help you
out she did help me out
wait I this is sick in the middle of the
game he's going to tell the real no I
don't fully remember so but I remember
his mom like he always bails them out
no it really bothers me right she like
told the coach that something else
happened
I don't really know who's agree with who
there buddy
anyway go on what did she do as she told
the coach like something else happened
yeah in the middle of the game I had to
leave the game because I had to go [__]
and I couldn't make it to the bathroom
and so it just got everywhere and then
my mom was like if you're aware like on
the fields as soon as I saw the toilet
just happened so like the steps leading
into the bathroom and then all over the
sort of like the walls and Stall oh my
God
primarily in my hands my legs and feet
[Laughter]
[Music]
I look like I picked up in a truck with
Chris Rock and Diplo it was truly crazy
oh God
I was probably like nine so how'd your
mom protect you so my mom came and she
was like oh God she's like flumming she
couldn't she never seen it we still
played soccer after that scar you from
playing that's the thing no one knew
what happened I kind of went to the
coach was like hey got a dash and he was
like all right you didn't say got a dash
of [__] on the floors of the bathroom
and I was like dude like I have to leave
I have to go so I like came off and like
he got a sub on and then I just left and
like kind of just phased out and then I
went [__] all over the ground and
basically none in the toilet which is
harder to do than what I did I think and
then my mom came up was like this is
crazy she picked me up got me like a
towel from the car like a wrapped to me
and like left all the clothes in the my
uniform in the bathroom just like you
hadn't ask
and then we got in the car we drove we
got clothes and then she was like we're
not going back to Camp that's it and I
was like okay and then she was like I'll
cover and then she kind of told the
coach that like there was a family
emergency
and that we had to leave at a certain
time and I got his attention and that we
had to go and then he left and then he
heard that some kids
your jersey was left there with the
number on the back of it yeah the trash
though the very bottom of the trash can
okay okay never stiff he's seen again
wait The Homeschool star before or after
that I'm saying I'm pretty sure
it was before that's why I wasn't good
at using the bathroom I was homeschooled
this whole time I never had to hold it
that's true so that was part of the
problem I've never had this why are you
holding your head so hard yeah
people get Diaries
not like that I have Celiac I have
Darius sensitivities
one time in your life and never again
well I learned I Grew From it I don't
know what happened I was like a
vaccination I kind of I had one bag what
was happening on the field like did you
did you feel it coming like no I can I
can keep playing yeah I just I mean I
felt bad the whole day I felt nauseous I
had my stomach was hurting
I've probably scored goals I can't even
really remember that part I think I was
playing pretty good I was running fast I
mean my legs were black but uh yeah I
was doing good I think and then and then
my diarrhea ruined it
that's part of the reason I didn't play
college ball I think was was partially
that day
I think if you look at my record it's
like a couple goals short I think it was
that half of a game that I had to get
subbed off for and it was a family
emergency so my mom didn't lie yeah
that's not the truth
yeah I wish I had a knife at that time
maybe things would have been different I
would have been able to defend myself
you wouldn't have stabbed yourself
you guys have never had childhood diver
why are you guys acting like I'm the
only one who died off on a bike I told
you that's my point yeah and you kept on
riding yourself on a bike yeah and you
kept battling yourself
on a down push my left leg I remember I
pedal down like that and the [__] right
came out
um it hit my underwear that were bagging
where it wasn't like tight ones and then
some of it fell out down my leg onto the
boardwalk yes and no chain is on the
right side of the bike right yeah yeah
so left pedal and then um yeah fell on
the boardwalk yeah I know what that
feels like but that seems much better it
seems like a deposit you know what I
mean yeah because you kept it moving
well I went to my friend's house it was
like right up the block and I went into
his bathroom and I didn't flush my
underwear I [__] up there I wrapped
the [__] that was left in the underwear
and I just put it in there garbage in
the bathroom and they called my parents
and they were like did Andrew [__] his
pain into his underwear and then leave
him okay why would they snitch if you
tried to flush it it wouldn't again
exactly so it's kind of the right thing
to do but I should have taken it with me
yeah
they would have still found out buddy I
don't know is this a white people thing
oh you've never [__] never [__] yourself
out I mean I have [__] stains in my
underwear many times but I've never [__]
stains that's [__] stains that's just
Tuesday that's all I've never no one not
ever on a [__] stands but I can't
believe you've never [__] yourself
you've never had a [__] stain you've
never sharted a couple times for sure
yeah I've sharted I'll tell this story
like come back from Philly and I had
like the spicy ties no you said you [__]
on the side of the highway
yeah I was just we're in a car on the
PCH there's not that many bathrooms I
had a bowel movement we had coffee in
the morning I had to go and so we pulled
off and it was a beautiful it's like
Sun's rise kind of thing where it's like
a sort of the size of the highway
looking at the Pacific Ocean it was
Immaculate and that's not shooting
yourself that is actually the preferred
way to [__] that's how most of us
yeah
you're talking about it that's exactly
my point what's going on here
like what's going on close calls like
everyone but nope not me you never shoot
yourself that's crazy I tell you I told
you my story and I that was bad for
everyone you never [__] in the shower
and then stomped it down
why dude oh just get away from you guys
this was an episode we appreciate you we
love you we'll see you on the bus
all right so what you're gonna do is is
you're gonna take my picks okay or
whatever picks you guys want but my
picks will probably be the right ones uh
has nothing to do with the fact that
Akash has the same picks disregard my
picks my picks are not I would actually
disregard his yeah with my pictures I
agree which are definitely Dallas
Cowboys Kansas City Chiefs which I have
picked because of all the football uh I
watch and uh so what I want you to do is
I want to go to prize picks.com and
you'll get a 100 deposit match up to 100
with the promo code Schultz think about
that okay think about that they're gonna
match your deposit up to a hundred
dollars when you use the promo code
Schultz at prize picks.com go get that
go get that money earn lots of it okay